[Musica]
Buon pomeriggio e per me è un onore
ovviamente aprire questo Tex e però
prima di farla parte del mio discorso
vorrei chiedervi un piacere allora
questo nome che voi Vedete l'ha già
detto prima è più lungo di un codice
fiscale non ci sono neanche gli accenti
quindi è facile cadere un po' in errore
si pronuncia aminata Gabriella fall Io
vi chiedo proprio un piacere Fatemi
sapere questo favore vi va di ripeterlo
insieme allora Al mio tre uno due tre
aminata Gabriella fall Ok grazie e
probabilmente è la prima volta dal 5
gennaio 79 il giorno in cui i miei hanno
deciso di darmi questo nome all'anagrafe
che viene pronunciato correttamente
perché poi anche i miei non l'hanno mai
usato tutto intero anzi solo Quando
camminavo qualche guaio probabilmente in
realtà mi chiamano tutti ami e io cresco
a Salò in provincia di Brescia e come
vedete dalla slide che anticipo ho
sempre cavalcato la tigre è un leone
Però fate per forza di fantasia
negli anni 80 si cresce si va alle
scuole pubbliche perché quelle private
soprattutto perlomeno dov'ero io non ce
n'erano e cresciamo tutti uguali siamo
tutti uguali e anche se io ero magari un
pochino meno uguale degli altri per
tanti aspetti ma soprattutto perché
venivo da una famiglia monogenitoriale
come si direbbe adesso Nel senso che mio
papà è mancato come ero piccola da
questa foto di classe dei tempi
dell'asilo Non si può capire chi sarà
quello che avrà successo chi viene da
una famiglia magari più benestante degli
altri siamo tutti uguali l'unica e siamo
quasi tutti pronti a prendere fuoco
grazie ai vestitini in poliestere che si
usavano all'epoca
la cosa bella del mio nome è che segna
prima ho sempre pensato che fosse un po'
una sciagura avere un nome così lungo in
realtà segna i vari modi in cui mi hanno
chiamato Segna un po' le tappe della mia
vita finisce la scuola le scuole
superiori finisco le scuole superiori e
io divento Dammi aminata full Cioè è il
modo in cui di solito uno legge il mio
nome su dettagli elenchi e Qui iniziano
i giochi inizia a farsi duro Nel senso
che io vorrei fare una certa università
ma ovviamente sono la prima di tre
fratelli e ci sono la mia mamma che
lavora quindi uno dei miei compiti è
quello di iniziare anche a lavorare
oltretutto ciò io cerco anche di
arrabattarmi questo è un linguaggio
tecnico per trovarmi una borsa di studio
per poter frequentare la facoltà che mi
sarebbe piaciuto fare Purtroppo però eh
sulla mia strada incontro uno studente
non è quello nella foto Una mia amica è
uno studente che
quel giorno la sera prima probabilmente
aveva fatto serata e siamo negli anni 90
quindi non ci sono Non c'è internet non
ci sono bisogna andare a cercare i
bigliettini foglietti dispense e mi dà
le informazioni sbagliate per ottenere
la borsa di studio quindi mestamente mi
iscrivo a Giurisprudenza a Brescia qui
sono estremamente arrabbiata Se pensate
una persona di 19 20 anni che si vede
dire no tu non sei uguale agli altri Se
tu non puoi fare quello che vuoi adesso
inizia la tua vita da adulta e non
lamentarti quindi c'è quello che devo
fare cioè dare una mano a casa lavorare
quello che voglio fare studiare e questo
mi butta in una grandissima frustrazione
fino a che a un certo punto
mi sveglio la mattina e ho un colpo di
fulmine non ci sono solo queste due vie
c'è anche quella che posso percorrere
cioè io voglio imparare le lingue voglio
fare una facoltà internazionale Va bene
Cercherò di adattare quella che sto
facendo A modo mio quindi al posto che
lavorare in Italia andrò a lavorare
all'estero in modo da imparare anche
delle lingue straniere
torno e dopo vado avanti e indietro vado
a dare gli esami torno all'estero
ritorno e divento Gabriella
Gabriella è quella che per puro caso
fondamentalmente finisce a lavorare in
banca perché all'epoca sia sempre prima
dell'ingresso dell'Euro si usavano le
varie valute per cui chi è più o meno
dei miei anni o anni precedenti ecco chi
non l'ha vissuto non è che sono vecchia
io siete troppo giovani voi facciamo
questa perversa e serviva in banca
qualcuno che cambiasse le valute e
quindi sapesse le lingue vengo quindi
assunta in banca e per me è stata la
pena del contrappazzo dantesco di fatto
io ho sempre odiato la matematica i
numeri cioè Lasciamo perdere quindi
mettere una persona che ha fatto ha
avuto una formazione umanistica dove la
risposta giusta a tutte le domande era
dipende
metterla a fare un lavoro da ragioneria
dove più meno deve comunque dare un
risultato è stato abbastanza dura fino a
che non mi sono accorta che se quei
numeri di cui io veramente non capivo
assolutamente niente diventavano soldi
Allora era tutto più facile da lì inizia
a fare la mia carriera cioè Cambio modo
di vedere questa sfilza di numeri e la
mia carriera inizia andare via Serena
e non ho foto del mio periodo in banca
Chissà perché però va bene Ci ho fatto
quasi 20 anni
a un certo punto però la mia vita
diciamo ho quasi 30 anni ho fatto tutto
quello che un giovane italiano nato
negli anni 80 avrebbe dovuto fare
secondo i suoi genitori trovati un
lavoro stabile
ma mi tira la giacchetta minata abbinata
mi dice Tu ti sei dimenticata
completamente una parte di te ed era
vero Nel senso che io del Senegal cioè
il paese di mio padre non sapevo
assolutamente nulla ne sentivo un po'
richiamo la curiosità Però non avevo il
coraggio di dire ho anche un lato
senegalese e i metodi che mi si
presentavano erano molto vicini
allappropriazione culturale Cioè nel
senso non era una mia cultura Cosa
faccio Mi faccio le treccine mi metto
una casacca non mi sembrava avesse molto
senso quindi ho pensato di unire le due
cose più belle che posso potevo che
posso fare in Italia e che potevo
portare insieme Gal sciare
Allora io non sapevo sciare Avevo appena
iniziato a far spazzaneve nel campetto e
dico a quello che all'epoca era il mio
fidanzato ora marito sai cosa io ti dico
una cosa io non solo Imparerò a sciare
Imparerò a sciare bene e poi andrò a
sciare per il Senegal e andrò alle
Olimpiadi
quando la spari così grossa ci sono due
opzioni uno ti danno una pacca sulla
spalla e ti fa pagare da bere Due ti
danno retta e quindi dopo devi pedalare
o sciare nel mio caso quindi a me è
successa la seconda mi hanno dato retta
ma dato retta anche il presidente della
federazione del Senegal e mi ha detto
guarda non c'è problema Se tu raggiungi
il punteggio per qualificarti alle
Olimpiadi quindi sciare per il Senegal
Quindi io per dieci anni mi sono
allenata ho vissuto da bancaria e poi
con i miei soldini Mi sono pagata tutto
quello che era necessario fra cui viaggi
trasferte in giro per il mondo per
provare a qualificarmi per le olimpiadi
per il Senegal Ah ecco la prima gara
l'ho fatta a Nevegal
[Risate]
[Applauso]
quindi non sono andata alle Olimpiadi Mi
dispiace non potete dire che avete visto
negli olimpionica comunque ma è viaggio
bellissimo e questo viaggio mi ha
insegnato che di fatto le strade non
battute o quelle che non si vedono in
realtà possono darti tantissimo ti fanno
anche spesso divertire Perché non hai
pressione non hai confronto con gli
altri e hai la possibilità di giocarti
davvero tutte le tue carte
Finisco questa carriera anche per
sopraggiunti i limiti di età e
un giorno inizio mi guardo intorno e
faccio mente locale Io ho lavorato in
banca per vent'anni e raramente ho
incontrato donne ovvero qualche collega
Sì però sono stata anche direttrice di
filiale e ho fatto un mutuo a una donna
per comprare casa
donne investitrici praticamente zero o
magari venivano col marito col compagno
quindi mi sono chiesta Ma dove sono le
donne Cioè siamo sono talmente ricche
che non ha bisogno delle banche o c'è
qualcosa di più ho approfondito il
discorso e
ho scoperto cose veramente piuttosto
tristi Nel senso che una donna su
quattro non ha un conto corrente che la
maggior parte delle donne non si sente
in grado di gestire i propri soldi
oppure hanno avuto anche esperienze
spiacevoli fra quali andare magari in
banca a sentirsi dire dall'addetto ai
finanziamenti o a quello degli
investimenti Sì ma passa con tuo marito
fidanzato tuo padre e quindi per vari
motivi le donne non si sentono accolte e
anche i giovani adesso non si sentono
accolte nel mondo dei soldi
era una strada piuttosto impervia però
ho detto ma io queste cose cioè le
informazioni di cui ha bisogno per
vivere serenamente Io le so tutte Quindi
nasce pecuniami un'altra versione del
mio nome per anni o sono stata appunto
lavoratrice in banca come Clark Kent e
Superman quindi di giorno in ufficio e
poi il fine settimana sui social per
raccontare e spiegare proprio in parole
povere Come funzionano i soldi come
approcciarsi in realtà al mondo del
denaro Come non farsi spaventare dal
bancalese che sono quelle parole
lunghissime che tanto piacciono gli
addetti ai lavori e
ci ho creduto Cioè ci credo in questo
progetto ci credo talmente tanto che
l'anno scorso al quinto mese di
gravidanza quindi avrei potuto godermi
una bellissima maternità da bancaria
cioè farsi veder tornare in ufficio nel
2000 mai fondamentalmente ma ho deciso
di lasciare il posto fisso
e di impegnarmi al 200%, in questo
lavoro che ovviamente mi dà tantissima
soddisfazione perché mi basta solo
sentire una ragazza che mi dice guardo
aperto il fondo pensione per sentirmi
veramente utile e aver veramente
raggiunto degli obiettivi e pensare
Quando sarai vecchia magari ti verrò in
mente Quindi quello che voglio dirvi è
che potete anche partire da punti un po'
svantaggiati avere i nomi complicati
pensare appunto di non essere di non
essere stati proprio Baciati dalla sorte
ma nessuno vi obbliga a competere con
gli altri per magari un posto Quando ce
ne sono altri milioni solo da inventare
Io adesso avrei finito Questo era il mio
speech ci tenevo a chiuderlo in questo
modo però visto che mi avanza un minuto
Vi chiedo un favore Visto che
probabilmente sarà l'ultima volta che
sentirò il mio nome detto bene nei
prossimi dieci anni vi va di ripeterlo
aminata Gabriella fall
Grazie
[Applauso]